listen do you hear that
my grandmother asked me listen listen to
what the beetle is saying I would spend
hours and hours listening to the little
beetle rolling a huge ball of dung and
while at it I heard a variety of
environmental sounds with a keenest of
ears I would hear family chatter
laughter the wind howling and even
crickets chirping all these sounds criss
crossed into each other and I would hear
rhythm in between then I would beat my
plate with a spoon and my chest with my
tiny hands trying to recreate what I was
hearing I have been beating the same
clades shakers drums pans and so much
more ever since to becoming a
professional drummer and percussionist
as I grew up subconsciously I felt a
strong urge to hide my newfound hobby
even without it being said out loud I
knew that somehow it was wrong to do
what I was doing in most of the
ceremonies I noticed that most of the
women and girls were not in sight but
when they were I noticed that they would
wear their dancing skirts and no shake
their waists off singing clapping you
lating while the men filled up the
rhythm section a few years later I came
to understand what tradition and culture
meant and what was considered taboo or
otherwise in majority of the African
cultures women have been forbidden to
play drums and percussion for a very
long time
I believe this taboo stems from the
psychological and traditional belief
that the woman is an inferior being I
grew up hearing that the place of the
woman is in the kitchen or in the other
room
women had been brainwashed and led on
for so long until we had fallen victims
and actually started believing in this
ourselves this coupled with the lack of
interest to educate women played a major
major role in edging this into our minds
the sounds of the drum provoked emotion
and movement essentially the drum is a
very essential instrument once at our
festival a man asked me how I dared put
a drum in between my legs I have been
considered loose and dirty for playing
an instrument I have repeatedly been
questioned why I would choose to play
drums instead of practicing journalism
which I studied for my undergraduate
which has been termed more decent the
sight of a woman playing drums and
Feebles her makes her less feminine less
desirable but all this optimally puts
her on a lower social stand
drumming has essentially represented
this strong African heritage and its
importance can be seen in the many
aspects of the African tradition many
communities encompass drumming and their
day-to-day activities and still do up to
date from child births to initiation
ceremonies welcoming ceremonies
marriages and even burials however this
same drum is disappearing very fast from
the music scene and the traditional
genre is losing its popularity very
quickly amongst the people inspired by
the need to preserve this culture I am
teaching the significance and the
importance of the drum to young boys
women and girls in my journey as a
percussion teacher I have realized that
very many women actually want to play
the drum but at the same time they fear
it some fear how society will perceive
them others fear the physical pain that
comes with playing oh yes it's not
some because the spouses don't approve
of them and others generally fear the
responsibility of being a bear of
culture I believe or I think that all
these fears are etched in the collective
feminine consciousness because when we
learn of the atrocities that have
happened to women continentally
especially it serves as a constant
reminder that one step out of our
designated place may end up in very
serious consequences well I use my drum
to tell my story and my peoples stories
my roots shaped me and my culture is
here to stay with me women can be
custodians of culture too we're born to
bring forth life to nurture it we can
definitely preserve what traditions very
very excellently my drum and I we're
here to stay we are definitely here to
stay if women have led countries women
have gone to space women have won
Grammys then the same same women can
play the drum and play it to a five star
rating no to a million star rating thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you